j'ai 57 ans
et je suis un gamin
la vie n'est qu'un jeu pas vrai tout
dépend de ta perception de la terre et
comment tu répliques
est-ce que ça ne t'a dit ce qui se passe
seulement que ce serait des hautes mises
certain que tu veux que ça se passe
comme ça
ça prend un bon catalyseur
mais j'ai surtout pas le temps
d'attendre que les gars soient
suffisamment à l'aise pour me dire la
vérité
santé ça fait trop longtemps
25 millions sur la table qui sont ces
gars c'est 5 millions en jetons et
j'aimerais jouer
pardonne-moi c'est quoi le piège bon il
y a pas de piège j'ai cru qu'on s'amuse
un peu
relance 175
en ligne
je vous ai empoisonné
non c'est pas drôle j'ai demandé à
l'univers quelques réponses j'ai jamais
rien reçu de vraiment satisfaisant je
suis prêt à mourir papa moi je me sens
pas très bien
tu es pas une autre de tes surprises qui
savent pas où on est on y va
personne ils sont cachés quelque part
je sais très bien que tu es
mais qu'est-ce qui est bonsoir
On est si ils sont trois on peut les
avoir
la vie n'est qu'un jeu pas vrai
maximiste
et reste dans le jeu ou si longtemps que
possible
[Musique]